[Musique]
mouscron à ça ça me suffit amplement à
ce qui existe en larmes et a forcément
le le pistolet automatique ou le temps
qu'il spéciales et les hammams
intermédiaires qui sont tout à fait
nécessaire aussi le bâton défense qui
lui est assez dissuasif et le pays est
encore plus dissuasif
et puis d'un intermédiaire par un spa
excellence et qui nous sort nous souvent
ne m'aurait pas notamment pour les
hospitalisations d'office aussi dans des
interventions ou de plus en plus on voit
d'ailleurs on essaie d'intimider la
police voilà donc avec un pays à la
ceinture c'est vrai que ça ça limite les
ardeurs et tout ça doit être associé à
mon sens par des caméras piéto qui
justifie les interventions qui peuvent
aussi apporter un visuel à nos élus
territoriaux et au hockey la ligue aux
gendarmes de sur ce qui s'est passé
dernièrement la police municipale n'est
pas forcément dans le même la même
situation en fonction des collectivités
territoriales s'est d'ailleurs qui que
la définition même d'une politique nul
et police municipale c'est qu'elle est
différente en fonction des territoires
et en fonction des moyens que les
collectivités peuvent mettre à
disposition de telle ou telle police et
on voit que des choix politiques par les
municipalités peuvent être différents
sur sa police municipale
certaines décident de refaire pape et
police davantage de proximité avec les
services publics avec les acteurs de la
ville notre violence la substituer à une
bande de police nationale 2 notamment
dans la lutte contre la délinquance et
la criminalité
est ce qu'on va donc nous nous rendrons
compte c'est que globalement elle est
très disparate en fonction des
territoires
on va protéger puisque on peut subir des
agressions
surtout quand on travaille en uniforme
comme comme nous en aucun cas on se
substitue à la police nationale a
rappelé que les maires sont dans
l'obligation d'assurer la sécurité de
leurs citoyens aussi en mettant des
policiers municipaux sur la voie
publique
il est d'un côté des expose donc c'est
pas parce que l'on fait de la proximité
combat sortir non plus voilà c'est ce
que je voudrais dire et puis c'est
pareil et forcené le maire doit faire en
sorte que les mutations d'office
est ce que on doit répondre maintenant
c'est pas le maire qui va sans doute
est-ce que ça va être la police d'état
je crois que tout le monde de la
récession
et justement l'application des points
celui du maire pour mener à bien nos
missions de police du maire
nous devons avoir nos moyens de
protection et d'intervention
quand vous êtes sur la voie publique et
vous êtes vous voyez un veulent se faire
ou à raquettes ou une agression
vous pouvez pas tourner les sur dix ans
de moins que moi si police municipale je
suis parent mais je peux pas intervenir
puis cet amoureux donc on va appeler les
forces de l'état
je pense en réalité qu'en faisant cela
on dira qu city mais les politiques qui
sont en oeuvre de désengagement de
l'état dans la police nationale
premièrement parce qu'en réalité on
vient justement opposé les mères à
allaiter en disant qu a vu que l'état ne
prend pas ses responsabilités le maire
va le faire je pense que c'est un
suspect en réalité la mairie devenir
davantage interpelle les pouvoirs
publics sur six si la sécurité des jeux
devraient interpeller les pouvoirs
publics à ce sujet et je pense qu'il ne
faut pas substituer les notes
ensuite le risque à armer la police
municipale modifier son rôle à l bd
aujourd'hui pour faire de la prévention
moi je ne vois pas l'intérêt l'intérêt
daele bd on va dans ce sens car je pense
qu'il faut davantage de fraîcheur que
man on va construire des droits pourquoi
pas des acteurs qui permet de faire le
lien entre la police municipale et les
autres aux acteurs si besoin mais pour
créer toujours davantage de proximité et
paramètres sont fous de la prévention si
on arrive à une escalade deux garnements
gars police et d'affrontements d'une
rare audace la police municipale et
affrontements avec avec une partie de la
population
en réalité la réaction escalade de la
violence qui a déçu et a pour père
seront davantage de richesse comment a
commencé la police municipale un rôle je
pense est essentielle
justement voilà prévention dont les
interventions auprès avec d'autres
services publics notamment de la
municipalité pour justement prévenir un
maximum les d'insécurité maintenant
j'entends le tapage nocturne
bon ben en premier lieu la police
municipale intervient c'est toujours la
première à intervenir à ce sujet si j'ai
un regret c'est à dégénère pas dans ce
cas là où il ya une police nationale qui
est également là pour y répondre mais en
fait c'est le go round directement dans
un système qui vient de mettre en
opposition
malheureusement une partie la population
et la police municipale risque d'être l'
escalade de la gorce et ses concerts la
proximité il ya des interventions dans
les quartiers qui peuvent être très
chaud justement en prévention et en
police de proximité sur les des
patrouilles de temps qu'ils étaient
punis où on peut être pris à partie et
je sais encore d'en faire un collègue
que parfois le vbc bien nécessaire pour
pouvoir se sauver d'un mauvais pas